التقى الرئيس الاوكراني
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان في كاف واكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
ان المملكه تبذل كل الجهود لتخفيف معاناه
الشعب الاوكراني كما قال ان المملكه قدمت
حزمتين من المساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه 410
ملايين دولار بدوره شكر الرئيس الاوكراني
المملكه على دعمها لجهود السلام
في هذا الاطار اكد ان اهتمام سيدي خالد بن
الحرمين الشريفين واسمه العهد في الجانب
الانساني في اوكرانيا كبير جدا وقد اتى
نتيجه ذلك توجيه القياده بتقديم حزبتين من
المساعدات الانسانيه لاوكرانيا بمبلغ
اجمالي 410 مليون دولار وقد وقعنا اليوم
على اتفقيتين تؤسس لتسليم هذه
الاعانات ونامل ان تكون
عونا في تخفيف معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في
هذه الازمه الانسانيه ولا شك ان المملكه
تبذل كافه الجهود التي من شانها التخفيف
من معاناه الشعب الاوكراني في الداخل
والنازحين في دول الجوار
كما اكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان حرص المملكه على حل الازمه
في اوكرانيا بالحوار وشدد على ضروره خفض
التصعيد وحمايه المدنيين
المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن في موقع السعوديه لان الذين
قناع راسخه ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون
بالحوار ويجب الكثور على طاوله المفاوضات
في اطار مبادئ القانون الدولي وميثاق
للامم المتحده واحترام سياده الدول ولهذا
سوف نستمر في العمل مع جميع الاطراف للبحث
عن فرص الوصول الى هكذا تسويه
كما التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان فور وصوله الى كيف مديره
مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني اندريه في مقر
الرئاسه بالعاصمه وجرس استعراض جهود
السعوديه الرميه الى ايجاد حلول سياسيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه واوجه المساعدات
المقدمه من السعوديه لاوكرانيا وشعبها
بهدف التخفيف من اثار الازمان ووقعت
السعوديه مع اوكرانيا مذاكره تفاهم
للمشتقات النفطيه وببرنامجا للعمل
الانساني كما اعلن الصندوق السعودي
للتنميه عن دعم اوكرانيا بالغاز المسال
ومشتقات النفط بمبلغ 300 مليون دولار
اهلا بك معنا تفاصيل هذه الزياره وابرز ما
جاء فيها
نعم اهلا بك ميسون اذا وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان يلتقي
اليوم ويصل الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
ثلاثه اجتماعات هي كانت اجتماعات مهمه
بداها مع مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكرانيه
السيد
هو الذي تحدث وكانت في مقر الرئاسه في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
طبعا من خلال اللقاء الاول استعراض
استعراض
الوزير الخارجيه السعودي وكذلك مدير مكتبه
الرئيس زرينسكي جهود المملكه في بايجاد
حلول سياسيه
للازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
اللقاء الثاني ايضا كان يجمع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي وكذلك الرئيس الاوكراني
وكان ايضا اجتماعا مطولا وكان على طاوله
الاجتماع تحدث في البدايه
وشكر الرئيس زلينسكي جهود السعوديه
الداعمه لحل الازمه وكذلك ايضا بعد هذا
الاجتماع كان هناك مراسم لتوقيع اتفاقيه
او مذكره تفاهم وكذلك توقيع لبرنامج مشترك
وهو المذكره الاولى لدعم
الاوكرانيه بمبلغ 300 مليون دولار
للمشتقات النفطيه والغاز المسال وسوف
يقدمها صندوق السعودي للتنميه وصندوق
التنميه السعودي واما البرنامج المشترك
الانساني وهو دعم للمساعدات للشعب
الاوكراني وسوف ومبلغهم 100 مليون دولار
وسوف يقدمه مركز الملك سلمان لغاته
والاعمال الانسانيه طبعا التوقيع جرى بين
الرئيس التنفيذي للصندوق سلطان المسجد
وكذلك من قبل المركز من لمعالي
والمسرف العام على المركز الدكتور عبد
الله الربيعه بحضور وزير الخارجيه السعودي
اللقاء الاخير وهو الاجتماع كان بين وزير
الخارجيه السعودي وكذلك وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني وتحدث ايضا في مجال التعاون
المشترك وايضا ايجاد حلول راميه ودعم
الجهود الدوليه الراميه للحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه الروسيه طبعا هذا ابرز
الاجتماع
ات الزيارات
لاول مسؤول في من دول المنطقه ومسؤول
سعوديه قوم ايضا او مسؤول عربي يقوم
بزياره
للعاصمه الاوكرانيه في ظل هذه الظروف طبعا
الزياره كانت هي زياره
رسميه من قبل الحكومه
الاوكرانيه والتي ايضا صدر فيها بيان
الرسمي او ثلاث بيانات الرسميه من قبل
المكتبه الرئيس وكذلك مدير مكتب الرئاسي
وايضا من وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه شكرا لك مفرد العربيه هاني
صفيان كنت معي من على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل